destiny's next expansion which is also
its biggest releases only a week from
now and while we can't jump into the
taking came just yet there are a few
things we can do to prepare horde almost
everything you have this includes
glimmer which is always useful and
telemetry which will help you level your
year two weapons faster as for the rest
of your materials keep them as well it's
unclear if weapon parts exotic shards
strange coins or motes of light will
have any use in the taken king but it
doesn't hurt to keep them in your vault
just to be prepared secondly collect
vanguard and crucible marks max them out
at 200 save every one of them when the
taken King releases both of these
currencies will become legendary marks
which will now span both PVE and pvp
rewards like the old marks these new
tokens can be exchanged for legendary
gear faction weapons and a variety of
class items the best way to collect
marks if you haven't already done so
it's the complete daily and weekly
content if possible run through the
weekly strike on the highest difficulty
this increases the Vanguard marks
awarded the nightfall strike in heroic
daily story also awarded generous number
of Vanguard marks making for an easier
trek to the 200 cap as for crucible
marks just keep playing PvP matches for
one week before the taken King launches
both new game modes and all eight maps
are free for everyone then you'll need
to buy it but you're watching this video
so I'll assume you're planning on doing
so already anyway before you get into
these crucible matches make sure you're
aligned with a crucible faction which
leads us to our next piece of advice
increase as many of your faction
reputations as possible the same goes
for your crypt dark rating but don't I
repeat do not actually rank up yet wait
until the taken king releases by
completing one last crucible match with
a dead orbit cloak on or returning one
less angry em to the Crypt dark you'll
tip the reputation rating and have a
reward waiting for you at the
postmasters Hut waiting until the
expansion releases will ensure your to
gear in faction packages these will far
outpace most of the items we're using
right now so there you have it although
the taken King doesn't release for a
week there are still ways to secure a
very high chance at good gear right out
of the gate destiny is undergoing
colossal changes over the next couple
weeks and these tips should give you a
good head start
you